je trouve ça ridicule avec tout l'argent
qui est investi dans les élections qui a
une faille aussi grosses que ça adèle et
sa dame n'est pas citoyen canadien il
est résident permanent pour la deuxième
fois depuis son arrivée au canada en
le jeune homme de 20 ans vient de
recevoir une carte d'électeur la
première fois ça s'est produit aux
élections provinciales
à un mois de faire mes 18 ans justement
j'ai reçu une lettre de d'élections
québec le qui me disait que j'allais
bientôt être éligible à pouvoir voter
le jeu fait comme moquetté j comme
ignorer la lettre parce que pour me le
dire que ça me concernait pas je pense
pas pouvoir voter
puis quand j'ai fait mes 18 ans plus
tard les élections semblaient mal agir
su l'être me disant que j'étais inscrit
à mon bureau et que je pouvais je
pouvais aller voter selon la loi
électorale du canada
les résidents permanents n'ont pas le
droit de vote pour le scrutin du 19
octobre
élections canada a envoyé 26 millions
400 mille cartes d'électeur au pays
les non inscrits proviennent de
différentes bases de données qui ne font
pas de distinction entre les citoyens
canadiens et les résidents permanents
car vous serez privé d'un de ses
lecteurs il est clairement demandé si
vous êtes citoyen si vous faites comment
on sera
est ce que ce sera comptabilisé pas
vraiment selon l'organisme le cas d'adel
et saddam
it is all i pourtant les deux frères du
jeune homme qui n'habitent pas à la même
adresse ont aussi reçu leur carte
d'électeur une situation qui préoccupe
le tunisien d'origine j'ai canada compte
plus de 260 mille résidents permanents
ces jeunes insiste c'est une démocratie
on dispose et d'avoir un système
d'élection démocratique blanc se
retrouve que quelqu'un c'est quelqu'un
de mal intentionné pourrait s'arranger
pour pouvoir aller voter quand même
parce qu'il ya une faille dans le
système bi des cas une faille banque
peut l'exploiter c'est logique nous
avons tenté de joindre le ministre
fédéral de la justice
pour clarifier cette situation mais en
vain de son côté élections canada
rappelle que c'est le devoir des
citoyens de signaler les erreurs ici
mélissa fauteuil radio canada à
sherbrooke